up until the 1970s cryptography had been
based on symmetric keys that is the
sender encrypts their message using a
specific key and the receiver decrypts
using an identical key as you may recall
that encryption is a mapping from some
message using a specific key to a cipher
text message to decrypt the cipher text
you use the same key to reverse the
mapping so for Alice and Bob to
communicate securely they must first
share identical keys
however establishing a shared key is
often impossible if Alice and Bob can't
physically meet or requires extra
communications overhead when using the
diffie-hellman key exchange plus if
Alice needs to communicate with multiple
people perhaps she's a bank then she's
going to have to exchange distinct keys
with each person now she'll have to
manage all of these keys and send
thousands of messages just to establish
them could there be a simpler way in
1970 James Ellis a British engineer and
mathematician was working on an idea for
a non-secret encryption it's based on a
simple yet clever concept lock and
unlock are inverse operations Alice
could buy a lock keep the key and send
Bob the open lock Bob locks his message
and sends it back to Alice no keys are
exchanged this means she could publish
the lock widely and let anyone in the
world use it to send her a message and
she only needs to keep track of a single
key
Ellis never arrived at a mathematical
solution though we had an intuitive
sense of how it should work the idea is
based on splitting a key in two parts an
encryption key and decryption key the
decryption key performs the inverse or
undo operation which was applied by the
encryption key to see how inverse keys
could work let's do a simplified example
with colors how could Bob send Alice a
specific color without Eve who is always
listening intercepting it the inverse of
some color is called a complementary
color which when added to it produces
white undoing the effect of the first
color in this example we assume that
mixing colors is a one-way function
because it's fast to mix colors and
output a third color and it's much
slower to undo Alice first generates her
private key by randomly selecting a
color say red next assume Alice uses a
secret color machine to find the exact
complement to her red nobody else has
access to this
this results in cyan which she sends to
Bob as her public key let's say Bob
wants to send a secret yellow to Alice
he makes this with her public color and
sends the resulting color back to Alice
now Alice adds her private color to
Bob's mixture this undoes the effect of
her public color leaving her with Bob's
secret color notice Eve has no easy way
to find Bob's yellow since she needs
Alice's private red to do so this is how
it should work however a mathematical
solution was needed for this to work in
practice the solution was found by
another British mathematician in
cryptographer Clifford Cox Cox needed to
construct a special kind of one-way
function called a trapdoor one
wavefunction
which is a function that is easy to
compute in one direction yet difficult
to reverse unless you have special
information called the trapdoor for this
he turn to modular exponentiation as
follows
take a number raise it to some exponent
dividing by the modulus and outputting
the remainder this can be used to
encrypt a message as follows imagine Bob
has a message which is converted to a
number M then he multiplies his number
by itself e times then divides this
result by a random number N and outputs
the remainder of the division this
results in some number see this
calculation is easy to perform
however given only C II and n it is much
more difficult to determine which M was
used because we'd have to resort to some
form of trial and error so this is our
one wave function that we can apply to M
it's easy to perform but difficult to
reverse this is our mathematical lock
now what about the key the key is the
trapdoor some piece of information that
makes it easy to reverse the encryption
we need to raise to some other exponent
safety which will undo the initial
operation applied to em and return to
the original message M so both
operations together is the same as M to
the power of e all raised to the power
of D which is the same as M to the power
of e times D is the encryption D is the
decryption therefore we need a way for
Alice to construct e and D which makes
it difficult for anyone else to find D
this requires a second one-way function
which is used for generating D for this
we look back to Euclid over 2,000 years
ago Euclid showed every number has
exactly one prime factorization which we
can think of as a secret key now it
turns out that prime factorization is a
fundamentally hard problem while
multiplication is easy let's clarify
what we mean by easy and hard by
introducing what's called time
complexity we all have multiplied
numbers before and each of us has our
own rules for doing so in order to speed
things up if we program a computer to
multiply numbers you can do it much
faster than any human can here's a graph
that shows the time required for a
computer to multiply two numbers the
time required to find the answer
increases as the number gets larger
notice that the computation time needed
is well under one second even with
fairly large numbers therefore it is
easy to perform
compare this to prime factorization if
someone told you to find the prime
factorization of 589 you will notice the
problem feels harder no matter what your
strategy will require some trial and
error until you find a number which
divides evenly into 589 after some
struggle you will find 19 times 31 is
the prime factorization if you are told
to find the prime factorization of
437,000 to
131 you'd probably give up and get a
computer to help you this works fine for
small numbers though if we try to get a
computer to factor larger and larger
numbers there is a runaway effect the
time needed to perform the calculations
increases rapidly as there are more
steps involved as the numbers grow the
computer needs minutes then hours and
eventually it will require hundreds or
thousands of years to factor huge
numbers we therefore say it's a hard
problem due to this growth rate of time
needed to solve it so factorization is
what Cox used to build the trapdoor
solution step 1
imagine Alice randomly generated a prime
number over a hundred and fifty digits
long call this p1 then a second random
prime number roughly the same size call
this p2 she then multiplies these two
prime numbers to get a number n which is
over three hundred digits long this
multiplication step would take less than
a second we could even do it in a web
browser
then she takes the factorization of n p1
times p2 and hides it now if she gave n2
anyone else they would have to have a
computer running for years to find the
solution step 2
Cox needed to find a function which
depends on knowing the factorization of
n for this you look back to work done in
1760 by Swiss mathematician Leonardo
Euler Euler continue to investigate
properties of numbers specifically the
distribution and location of prime
numbers one important function he
defined is called the v function it
measures the break ability of a number
given a number say n it outputs how many
integers are less than or equal to n
that do not share any common factor with
n for example if we want to find Phi of
8 we look at all values from 1 to 8 then
we count how many integers 8 does not
share a factor greater than 1 with
notice 6 does not count because it
shares a factor of 2 while 1 3 5 and 7
are counted as they only share a factor
of 1 therefore Phi of 8 equals 4 what's
interesting is that calculating the Phi
function is hard except in one case look
at this graph it's a plot of values of
Phi over integers from 1 to a thousand
notice any predictable pattern the
straight line of points along the top
represent all the prime numbers since
prime numbers have no factors greater
than 1 the Phi of any prime number P is
simply P minus 1 to calculate Phi of 7 a
prime number we count all integers
except 7 since none of them share a
factor with 7 5 7 equals 6 so if you are
asked to find Phi of 20 1377 a prime
number you'd only need to subtract one
to get the solution 20 1376
Phi of any prime is easy to compute
this leads to an interesting result
based on the fact that five function is
multiplicative that is Phi a times Phi B
equals Phi a times B if we know some
number n is a product of two primes P 1
and P 2 then Phi of n is just the value
of 5 for each prime multiplied together
or P 1 minus 1 times P 2 minus 1 we now
have a trapdoor for solving Phi if you
know the factorization for n finding Phi
n is easy for example 7 times 11 equals
77 so Phi of 77 is 6 times 10 equals 60
step 3 how to connect the Phi function
to modular exponentiation for this he
turn to euler's theorem which is a
relationship between the phi function
and modular exponentiation as follows M
to the power of Phi n is congruent to 1
mod n this means you can pick any two
numbers such that they do not share a
common factor let's call them m and n
for example M equals 5 and N equals 8
now when you raise m to the power of Phi
N and divide by n you will always be
left with 1 now we just need to modify
this equation using two simple rules
first if you raise the number 1 to any
exponent K you will always get 1 in the
same way we can multiply the exponent
Phi n by any number K and the solution
is still one second if you multiply 1 by
any number say M it always equals M in
the same way we can multiply the
left-hand side by
to get em on the right hand side this
can be simplified as M to the power of K
times Phi n plus 1 this is a
breakthrough we now have an equation for
finding e times D which depends on Phi n
therefore it's easy to calculate D only
if the factorization of n is no meaning
D should always be Alice's private key
it's the trapdoor which will allow her
to undo the effect of e let's do a
simple example to see all of this in
action say Bob has a message he
converted into a number using a padding
scheme let's call this M Alice then
generates her public and private key as
follows first she generates two random
prime numbers of similar size and
multiplies them to get n 3127 then she
calculates Phi of n easily since she
knows the factorization of n 3016 next
she picks up some small public's phone
and E with the condition that it must be
an odd number that does not share a
factor with Phi n in this case she picks
e equals 3 finally she finds the value
of her private exponent D which in this
case is 2 times Phi of n plus 1 divided
by 3 2011
now she hides everything except the
value of N and E and an e make up her
public key think of it as an open lock
she sends this to Bob to lock his
message with Bob locks his message by
calculating m ^ e mod n
call this see his encrypted message
which he sends back to Alice
finally Alice decrypts his message by
using her private key D accessed through
a trapdoor C ^ D equals Bob's original
message M notice that Eve or anyone else
with C N or E can only find the exponent
D if they can calculate Phi of n which
requires they know the prime
factorization of n if n is large enough
Alice can be sure that this takes
hundreds of years with even the most
powerful network of computers this trick
was immediately classified after its
publication however was independently
rediscovered in 1977 by Ron Rivest Adi
Shamir and Len Adleman which is why it
is now known as RSA encryption RSA is
the most widely used public key
algorithm in the world and the most
copied software in history every
Internet user on earth is using RSA or
some variant of it whether they realize
it or not its strength relies on the
hardness of prime factorization which is
a result of deep questions about the
distribution of prime numbers a question
which has remained unsolved for
thousands of years
[Music]
you
[Music]